a good first kiss can make for an iconic
moment in movie history and turn a great
film into something unforgettable but
which on-screen kisses are the best of
the best
from superhero smooches to prom night
pecks these are the very best first
kisses in cinematic history
throughout the princess bride buttercup
and wesley share plenty of kisses or
they probably do at least
it's just that the audience never gets
to see them this is because the grandson
being told their story isn't really into
hearing about the kissing scenes
what is this are you trying to trick me
and
where's the sports is this a kissing
book
so although wesley and buttercup seem to
have had a truly epic first kiss earlier
in the film it's not really properly
shown
at the end of the movie however
buttercup and wesley ride off into the
sunrise together
the grandson has been so moved by their
tale of love that he allows his
grandfather to keep reading
and the film finally shows the two
heroes smooching with the grandfather
aptly narrating
since the invention of the kiss there
have been five kisses that were rated
the most
passionate the most pure this one left
them all
behind the back to the future franchise
is one of the most fun sci-fi trilogies
around but it's a little lacking in the
romance department
marty and jennifer aren't exactly swoony
and though doc brown and clara clayton
get all googly-eyed in the third movie
their relationship is more adorable than
it is passionate
but george and lorraine are truly meant
to be especially if marty wants to stop
himself fading into nothingness
for most of the movie lorraine outright
ignores george but when george saves her
from bip their passions ignite
the first kiss on the dance floor while
the band sings earth angel is a little
bit naughty a little bit nice and
altogether unforgettable
and it saves marty's bacon too which is
never a bad thing
atonement tells the story of cecelia and
robbie two youngsters deeply in love
unfortunately their romance is thwarted
by the outbreak of world war
ii and the devious machinations of
cecelia's younger sister bryony
but early in the film before tragedy
strikes cecilia and robbie get to share
a few intimate moments together
first there's that flirtatious scene by
the fountain where cecelia dives in to
retrieve a piece of broken vase wearing
nothing but a slip
when she emerges soaked robbie doesn't
look away and naturally cecilia doesn't
want him to either
all that tension is released later when
an unusually well-dressed robbie meets
cecilia for a fancy dinner party
in the darkened library the two lovers
finally collide and kiss like they've
never kissed before
william shakespeare's romeo and juliet
is one of the most popular love stories
ever told
sure it doesn't exactly end well but
this story has stolen the hearts of
lovers around the world ever since it
was written
and it's been adapted for the silver
screen a number of times one of the best
cinematic adaptations of this timeless
love story is baz luhrmann's romeo and
juliet
in which claire danes and leonardo
dicaprio play the famous star-crossed
lovers in lerman's movie their first
kiss takes place in an elevator in the
midst of a dazzling costume party
juliet wears a white dress and angel
wings while romeo is in a knight's armor
making both of them look decidedly
shakespearean despite the modern setting
their flirtatious meat cute unfolds
while desiree's kissing you plays
and escalates into the frenzied lip lock
in the elevator perfectly capturing the
whirlwind of their doomed relationship
star wars as princess leia and han solo
have a relationship wrought with
bickering sexual tension love and
tragedy
but their first kiss starts a romance
that goes on to cross the galaxy survive
the fall of an empire and last for many
decades
and the empire strikes back as leia is
trying to fix a bit of machinery
han approaches her from behind they
flirt a little and fight a little and
then han takes his chance
recently some fans have criticized this
kiss as well as the early stages of the
relationship in general
citing han's aggression and persistence
as kind of problematic
and while it's fair enough it's
undeniable that for many star wars fans
this kiss is an iconic declaration of
both han and leia's love
etv extraterrestrial isn't a
particularly romantic movie and it
doesn't really feature a love story per
se but
sparks nonetheless fly albeit briefly in
steven spielberg's story of a lost
lonely boy and his alien companion
with elliot off at school and e.t left
alone at home the abandoned alien gets
into some beers in the fridge and puts
on a john wayne movie
at this point elliott can feel et's
feelings so he acts drunk frees a bunch
of frogs and starts a bit of a classroom
riot
as e.t watches john wayne and maureen
o'hara embracing a passionate kiss
elliott nabs the girl with a crush on
him gets a boost from another classmate
and plants a kiss on her
john williams classic score sweeps over
the whole moment making it a kiss as
stirring and memorable as it is utterly
bizarre
the first kiss in goodwill hunting isn't
so much passionate or sexy as it is
totally adorable
it's a kind of kiss that comes from pure
comfort with another person
and the chemistry needed between two
actors to make it work during the movie
the titular character will take skyler
out on a date at a low-key burger joint
as the two chat and flirt the chemistry
between them becomes palpable
no you know i tell you i was hoping to
get a good night late
[Laughter]
kiss their witty banter comes to a head
however when skyler suggests they get
their good night kiss over with before
the end of the night
and inevitably this happens a film
already cited is one of the best of the
century so far
moonlight features a number of
revolutionary love stories between black
men
both familial and romantic the first
kiss between chiron and kevin is a
tender intimate moment filled with
excitement trepidation and hope
when the moment went on to win best kiss
at the mtb movie awards actor ashton
sanders said
this represents more than a kiss this is
for those who feel like the others the
misfits
this represents us meanwhile jarel
jerome added
this award is for us artists who are out
there who need to step out of the box to
do whatever it takes to get people to
wake up
many spider-man have taken to the silver
screen since toby maguire first flung
his web in 2002 spider-man
but his kiss with kirsten dunst's mary
jane is still commonly regarded as one
of the most iconic movie moments a
character has ever had
after rescuing mj from some muggers
spidey hangs upside down from a building
as he makes sure she's alright
there's a little flirting naturally nice
to have a fan
do i get to say thank you this time and
then mj decides to thank him properly
pulling his mask down to the bridge of
his nose and giving him a rain-soaked
upside down kiss
one that went straight into the
hollywood history books
there's really no denying that emma
stone and ryan gosling have some serious
chemistry together
while la la land saw them fall in love
through song and dance however things
get a little more r-rated and crazy
stupid love
and in this movie their first kiss is
just an appetizer to the rest of their
evening together
devastated after not getting the
proposal she expected from her boyfriend
hannah marches through the reign back to
a bar where gosling's character jacob
hit on her a few nights prior
looking for a quick hookup hannah
marches over to jacob while he's hitting
on another girl and plants a hard long
kiss on him jacob of course takes the
hint and quickly lifts her off her feet
it doesn't take long before the two are
heading home together
the romance between steve rogers and
agent peggy carter is one that spans
almost a century
luckily it all turns out pretty well at
the end of avengers end game after steve
travels back in time to place the
infinity stones back where they belong
he decides to stay in the 1940s with
peggy and live out the rest of his life
with her
and it all begins with one quick kiss in
2011's captain america the first avenger
as cap peggy and colonel chester
phillips chase down the red skull's
plane cap prepares to jump off their
jeep and head into paddle
before he departs peggy grabs him by the
collar and plants a kiss on him
it's not particularly long but it is
passionate and sparks a love that defies
time itself
an adaptation of the racy 1782 novel
liaison don chorus
cruel intentions is salacious to say the
least and famously features a racy kiss
between selma blair and sarah michelle
geller's character cecile and catherine
though the moment is a bit of a tease at
the time it was still revolutionary to
see two people of the same sex kissing
in a mainstream movie
as chelsea steiner at the mary sue put
it while the kiss was gratuitous and
very much for the male gaze
it was many of our first experiences
seeing any kind of queer kissing on the
big screen
for many queer women and folks that kiss
was something of a light bulb moment
as harry potter grows up throughout the
eight movies in his franchise he goes on
through all the typical teenage rites of
passage crushes breakups first kisses
and all
and while the harry potter movies
feature some great kisses it's harry's
very first smooch that remains the
series most memorable
harry has his first kiss with his crush
cho chang and a romantic moment under
the mistletoe but it's an experience
harry later describes as wet
due to cho crying during the act and no
it's not that harry is a terrible kisser
as hermione explains paul obviously
she's feeling sad about cedric
and therefore confused about liking
harry and guilty about kissing him
teenagers right there are a ton of
steamy scenes in dirty dancing
so many in fact that it might be
difficult to precisely recall when baby
and her dance instructor johnny first
kiss
indeed they get so close so often
throughout the movie that you might be
forgiven for thinking they're kissing
pretty much the whole time
but baby in johnny's first kiss actually
goes way farther than just a kiss
it finally happens during the scene in
which they sleep together for the first
time
which was kind of a scandalous thing for
a couple to do back in 1963.
so how does it go down well baby heads
up to johnny's shack of an apartment and
finally confesses her love the two then
seductively danced to solomon burke's
1962 song cry to me gyrating and dipping
before they eventually disrobe
at long last they kiss one another
before lying down on the bed and
well you know james cameron's titanic is
probably one of the most romantic movies
ever made yet it's also shrouded in
tragedy
but even in the depths of the film's
saddest moments the romance between jack
and rose is a stalwart life preserver
their big moment comes on the ship's bow
right after rose has decided to get off
the boat with jack when they dock
at this moment bathed in the glow of the
setting sun jack and rose finally kiss
but then as the scene transitions the
two lovers fade into the sea
as the titanic's shining bars transform
into those long sunk beneath the waves
jack and rose do get a few more moments
together before the end but it's their
first kiss that's the most romantic
and most haunting of all check out one
of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one